LEIGHA JARETT: In
our last episode
of "BigQuery
Spotlight," we walked
through the structure and
components of the BigQuery
resource model.
In this episode, we're
drilling in deeper on tables,
covering each of the
different table types
and when to use them.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what is a table?
A BigQuery table
is a resource that
lives inside of a data set.
It contains individual
records organized into rows,
with each record composed
of columns or fields
that have an enforced data type.
BigQuery supports many
different data types,
including decimal
representations for precision
in financial use cases,
geography for geospatial data,
plus structs and arrays
for complex data.
Oh, and keep an eye
out for more data
types that will support
semi-structured data, coming
soon.
Aside from simply
storing your data,
tables can also be
used to control access
to information and store
metadata, such as descriptions
and labels.
There are several different
types of tables in BigQuery,
so let's go ahead and
dig deeper into each one.
The first table type we'll
talk about is a Managed Table.
Managed Tables are tables
where data is saved
in BigQuery's native storage.
Let's jump into the console
and create a new Managed Table.
When getting started
with BigQuery,
you might already have
some data that you
want to load into a table,
such as a CSV file living
on your computer.
Here, you can specify a local
file and leverage schema
auto detect so that BigQuery
infers the name and data
type of each column.
Alternatively, you may want to
create an empty table, where
new rows will be inserted
through data pipelines.
In this case, you'll use
the "create table" statement
in a SQL query to
create a new Managed
Table with a specified schema
and a set of configuration
options.
This is going to be
a pretty big table,
so let's take it
one step further
and include partition
and cluster keys
so that BigQuery stores the data
in a way that will make queries
much more performant.
Another great thing
about Managed Tables
is that you can use time travel
to access data that has been
changed in the past seven days.
So no need to panic
if you accidentally
erase a row or a table.
You can still query data that
was deleted or has expired.
Now, what if your
data is already
stored somewhere else,
like a data lake located
in a Cloud Storage Bucket?
Other systems might also
be accessing this data,
say, Spark Workflows running
on a Dataproc cluster.
If you took the approach
of replicating the data
in a Managed Table, you would
have two different versions,
one stored in Cloud
Storage and one
stored in BigQuery, which could
lead to mismatching analyses.
This situation is
a good use case
for our second type of table.
External Tables give you
the ability to query data
that's stored
outside a BigQuery,
preserving a single
source of truth.
BigQuery currently
supports querying data
stored in Cloud
Bigtable, Google Drive,
and Cloud Storage, which
can include leveraging
Hive-based partitioning.
Let's create an External Table
that points to a JSON file
living in our Storage bucket.
This time, you'll specify
that it's an External Table
and also specify the format
and file path for the data.
You can now join this data
onto other tables in BigQuery,
so long as it's stored
in the same region.
Aside from creating an
External Table in BigQuery,
you can also create
a Connection,
which is more like
an external data set.
A Connection links BigQuery
to a Cloud SQL database
and allows you to
create external queries.
An external query
executes the query
in Cloud SQL and
returns results which
you can leverage in BigQuery.
Both Connections
and External Tables
are examples of
Federation, meaning
BigQuery will go and fetch the
data from the external source
at the query's runtime.
This offers a great
approach to ensure everyone
in your organization is working
off of the same data sources.
However, you should keep in mind
that query performance probably
won't be as high
as querying data
in native BigQuery storage.
So far, we've talked
about tables stored inside
of BigQuery and tables
stored outside of BigQuery.
But let's imagine that you want
to create an aggregate version
of an existing BigQuery table--
for example, a sum
of sales each day.
You could create a
whole new Managed Table
using a SQL query,
but you would need
to rerun that statement each
time the aggregate table needs
to be refreshed.
A better option
is to use a View.
Views are virtual tables that
are defined by a SQL query.
In BigQuery, you can create
a Logical View, a View where
the defining query is
simply executed at runtime,
or you can create a
Materialized View,
which is re-computed
in the background
when the base table changes.
Materialized Views are great
for improving performance,
because the results are
saved and reused, as opposed
to rerunning the query each
time you're leveraging the View.
And better yet,
BigQuery will actually
reroute queries
against your base table
to the Materialized
View in order
to make things more efficient.
However, there are some
limitations on the SQL
you can use.
But these are in flux, so keep
an eye out on future releases.
On the other hand,
Logical Views are
less restrictive in the terms
of SQL that you can use.
Logical Views are also really
useful for granting users
access to results of a query,
even if they don't have access
to the underlying data set.
This is known as
an Authorized View.
For more details, check out our
previous video, linked below.
Congrats!
Now you know all the
different table types
in BigQuery and some best
practices on when to use them.
For more guidance on getting
started with BigQuery
or digging deeper into
BigQuery resource concepts,
check out the links below.
Thanks for joining us today
for "BigQuery Spotlight."
Watch out for the next episode,
and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]